on the remote thai-burma border a
Cayenne tribes woman is about to
discover how her body has suffered for
tradition 19 year old ma Blaine is
having her neck rings removed for the
first time in five years and while they
look like rings the brass collar is
actually a single brass coil wound
around the neck
traditionally they only come up during
childbirth at doctor's visit or if the
woman is caught committing adultery in
that case she will pay for her
infidelity with an exposed neck for life
there are stories of women being
asphyxiated when their neck piece was
removed their weakened muscles unable to
support the head but according to Lorna
McMillan this has no basis in fact
contrary to some of the beliefs
it doesn't actually support the head so
it's not so tight that it isn't allowing
the neck a lot of movement in fact the
women can put their hands down and you
know clean and reach their skin and all
of that so it's not actually something
that's that's sort of gripping them in
any way for the first time since she was
a young girl ma Blaine is about to find
out just how much the neck piece has
changed brass is a tough metal it takes
village elder Manang nearly an hour to
loosen it by hand
finally the job is done it's the moment
MA Blaine's been waiting for
if I thumb that look at my neck
what does it look like is it white Oh
black mob lanes friend quickly reassures
her no mom it looks whiter yeah oh ho
it's the first time mob lanes seen her
neck in five years I was wondering all
the time how my neck would look would it
be black or white mob leans neck and
shoulders are scarred from where the
heavy rings have gouged and dug into her
flesh her neck feels very light without
the weight it's not uncommon for Chi and
women to become light-headed and dizzy
after their rings are removed
ma Blaine wants to show her bare neck to
her friends but feels so strange with it
naked that she soon covers it with a
scarf before she goes outside in
Mobley's world an exposed female neck is
an oddity this rare sight fascinates her
friends